in this video we'll talk about protein
tagging
protein tags are peptide sequences which
are genetically grafted onto a
recombinant protein tags are attached to
the protein and they are useful for many
purposes there are many type of tags
such as gfp tag ha or Mick tag histag
Etc but the big question is what are the
application of protein tagging
now let us try to understand that there
are many applications such as protein
purification studying subcellular
localization of the protein protein
protein interaction and protein
interactive analysis
so in this video we will study at least
few of them so let's study how tags
could be useful to understand
subcellular localization of the protein
let's say we want to ask whether our
protein X is localized inside the
nucleus or Golgi or wherever in the cell
how to ask that question in order to
understand that
we have to tag this protein and we can
tag that using our expression Vector we
can put a n terminal or a c-terminal gfp
tag transfect those plasmid into the
cell and whenever D there would be
translation of these plasmid a gfp
tagged protein would be generated
whenever these protein would be
localized we can understand the
localization of the protein with the
help of fluorescence in this case the
protein localization is predominantly in
the nucleus
now point to be noted that
immunohistochemistry method can also
talk about the protein localization but
it cannot tell us the protein
localization in real time
with the endogenous protein tag we would
be able to monitor the protein
localization in real time inside a live
system
the next application comes is like
protein purification in a biochemistry
lab on a day-to-day basis you need to
purify protein and in order to purify
protein from a mixture of protein you
need your protein of interest to be
tagged one of the popular tag is
histidine tag or histag protein
purification I have a detailed video on
that but in short using this particular
technique you generate a hiss stacked
protein which binds to a nintm matrix
and thereby the separation is easier
so in this method also a Hester hexade
hex histidine tag is incorporated at the
genetic level in this expression vector
and then it is
transfected onto the cells either
mammalian cells or also in the bacteria
then when we lie these cells and try to
purify these protein obviously our
protein would be having this hexa his
histidine tag which can
separate them or discriminate them from
other protein mixtures and thereby we
can isolate our protein of Interest with
column chromatography in general there
are several steps in the column
chromatography not going into details
but our protein of Interest could easily
be purified from a pool of protein using
this methodology
so this is one kind of affinity
purification as well
now as a third application we can study
protein protein interaction using
protein tagging methods
in this particular method we would be
tagging protein with fluorophores or
fluorescent proteins for example
cyan fluorescent protein or yellow
fluorescent protein now we can perform
the froster resonance energy transfer
technique to understand whether these
two proteins are interacting with each
other or not
if they are interacting there would be
fret if they are not interacting there
would be no Freight so presence of fret
would tell us about the protein protein
interaction
again in order to perform that we need
to get our protein of interest in a
particular expression Vector where cfp
and yfp is already there so we have to
clone it with the yfp and cfp tag and
then express it in a mammalian cell or
in other systems then only we can
perform the Fret experiments for our own
purposes
so at least we looked at three examples
or three uh cases where protein tagging
is really useful in biomedical research
if you want more notes or flashcards you
can visit my Facebook page or Instagram
Channel
all the links are in the description you
can support our Channel by clicking on
the super thanks option your small
contribution means a lot for me see you
in next video